[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is our chance
to control the truth
the concepts of right and wrong from
everyone for centuries to come
[Music]
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a sign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
another Gonna Stand Down I'm not the one
to fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming
it was all a dream
[Music]
[Applause]
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know that you know
oh he's here
[Music]
Charter 373
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
[Music]
we've crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I don't know where we are
I've located One Survivor
a giant
foreign
foreign
you and I are gonna get home oh finally
ready
laughs
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you think your wife can hear you
no
white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
I'm going to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
the new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds
no management we've known each other
since we were
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried
I'm going to need a gun
by my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
you'll have your freedom
the old laws only one can survive
here to meet at sunrise
for results and execution
Last Words Winston
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after a good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]
we were gone for quite a while
no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude
don't forget
where we came from
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last one last time
to the forever
are good
[Music]
[Applause]
and they'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
Captain Torrance flight Commander how
can I help you fugitive extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of passengers I'm afraid
you're stuck with this captain
get them on board let's have a good
flight
right through the top of the storm
keep everybody in their seats no
exceptions all right
[Music]
we are dark
foreign
the Jolo Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there
anymore
the clock is ticking every minute
matters
[Music]
we can count those minutes in lives lost
or saved
we don't know who it is listen carefully
this is an emergency I'm captain Brody
Torrance
foreign
England
country
[Music]
my passengers my responsibility I'm
gonna need your help you're gonna need
this
perform a militarism you can say that
then why'd they lock you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual places
foreign
we're getting off this island
[Applause]
[Applause]
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing
doesn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need to give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right I know you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made the plants so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense but everywhere I go people tell me
the same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help that that's why
we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
Army am I gonna come down
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
so afraid of it
there's something I never told you
[Music]
nice
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
in days of Legend gods
walked the Earth
[Music]
say it what if I told you
Cena had returned in human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
[Music]
foreign
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman is so cool and I'm just
me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers but
there's everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
the fate of the world depends on it
coming for you
[Music]
children stored the power of all the
gods
very personal Billy
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but in all of the Fast and the
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family guys that was a signal
introducing
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't really everyone can be
worthy let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
I miss the desert
I miss the sea
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us
those days have come and gone Perhaps
Perhaps not
[Music]
I don't believe in magic
I've seen things
things I can't explain
and I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe
hard to believe
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
get back
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
this is built on their shoulders
can I help you let me get the autograph
no I ain't sounding an autographs but
you get off my car you don't remember me
huh
[Music]
damn you
how long were you locked up
16 years bro just got out last week
got the head back up I know I've been
away a long time but I got myself in
shape I still got gas in the tank come
by the gym
thank you
[Music]
carers what happened with you two oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though man I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad try spending half your
life in a cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Damien was like family
[Music]
oh we passed talking then maybe you just
have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me
[Music]
yeah I ain't scared of that did you hear
me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is
[Music]
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just
just see my little man not be my little
boy all the time
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
but he feels like he belongs wherever he
wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you moms
they won't look out for you like us
want to get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
and he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
no
[Music]
Mr Russell
how would you say things have been for
you since your return to society
it's good to have you back
one last job
it's got to be smooth
to wait for the armored car to arrive
when it does
The World Is Ours
[Music]
and Clean Cash in the back
see that weapons training
military I'm gonna get him
I just got something it's a bank job 600
000 for one day's work not too bad right
you stick with your plan
[Music]
[Applause]
this one we can't lose
everybody get down they going down like
that son this is my show
she went in
here in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hurry up
[Music]
you come with us
can you get that bullet out need to look
at it first that's what I'm dealing with
Daddy yes that's what I just said I keep
driving do we figure our next move
left now
nope nope
[Music]
our car broke down a couple miles back
I just wanted a place to sit for a few
hours
okay why are you all alone
my grandpa's running ass
what is this place
yourself for right you're a little fun
house down here just go this isn't safe
for who
[Music]
you don't even know what you're dealing
with we'll find out
now
[Applause]
now the fun begins
[Music]
we need to get you out of here it's the
night before your wedding and you can't
spend the night together it's bad luck
we're growing adults we're fine no
actually you should go it's tradition
see she gets it I just want to ask is
that genetics or is it like Pilates
strands in your eyes they color them
wonderfully we got your gift it's just
something borrowed brings you good luck
except for Uncle Greg who ended up
captivated on that forklift but that's
not the knives fall oh someone just left
it in the bathroom
look at you I think the left boob is
slightly lower than the right boom
[Music]
[Applause]
it's normal to feel scared remember
anything happen to your family I'm also
feeling scared like the most scared I've
ever been in my whole life it's like I
just watched the ring you know
[Music]
we're gonna fix it
nobody with my family
love me
[Music]
your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife
[Music]
foreign